Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab.
We're continuing with our live performance
of apocalyptical from the paramount
Peter in Seattle, Washington.
And we just heard a new theory
about the end of the dinosaurs,
a very sudden fast, dramatic end with
a sudden musical boom at the very,
very end. Now for the next question, this
is sort of the obvious next question,
uh,
which is what made it through and how
well we did ask scientists that question
and here is what they told us.
[inaudible] if on that day you were a
creature in the ocean and you happened to
be within 300 feet of the water surface.
So you imagine this room
filled with ocean water,
we're talking about you guys up in the
balcony up there will not surprise you to
learn. You don't do very well. Uh,
there's a certain amount of heat and
mostly there's acid rain pouring in.
So a lot of you will die.
Look down with the higher paying
seats if you're below 300 feet.
And this always happens to people with
different, with the better anyway.
You do find,
and on land it turns out plain
ordinary dirt is a very good insulator.
If you've got 1200 degrees on
the surface, then about three,
four inches down, you'd be comfortable
there for several hours. Oh,
just a couple inches. You
only need a few inches.
So that means you could be a little warm
and if you squiggle down, you're okay.
You could be a Beatle
squiggling down. You're okay.
You could be a dinosaur
tending to an underground nest.
And if the nest isn't far
enough below the ground,
and a lot of them were,
then the babies that hatch will have
babies that hatch will have babies that
hatch, we will call their
babies and years later birds.
And if you're an early
version of a crocodile,
you bury yourself deep
enough into the mud.
You also get through as do the plant's
roots. A lot gets through action.
And that actually brings us to, uh,
what I find to be one of the
coolest parts of this story.
This is the part that involves
all of us in this room.
So it turns out on that day as the
fire was raging above on the surface,
somewhere in a little hole in the ground
happened to be a furry little animal.
It has the distinction of being the same.
Great. Great, great, great, great, great,
great, great, great, great,
great, great, great, great, great,
great, great. Okay, great.
Great, great. Okay, great.
Et cetera. Grandma of everybody
in this room. It is true.
There was a creature down there. Um,
there is a creature down there.
I thought we should stop there
because we were getting away with
something and I didn't
want to push it too far.
All of a sudden it was just usually, yeah.
Though there is a creature
down there, uh, in a,
in a little hole and when the
dinosaurs got cleared away,
this creature could step out of her
hole. She could step out of her niche.
She had more food, more places to roam.
She could populate the planet
ushering in the age of mammals.
And now here we all are in Seattle. Oh,
don't flatter yourself. It's not a
straight line. It's a weekly lie.
Well, here's the problem.
We've never known anything about this
animal that gave rise to all of us.
We've never known what she looked
like. We've never known, uh,
you know how she spent her days who'd
never known anything cause we've had no
fossils of her. But recently actually,
literally as we were reporting this story
right in the middle of our reporting,
uh,
a team of scientists led by a woman named
Maureen O'Leary who is herself a memo.
She took, uh, fossils that we do have
fossils of this creature's descendants.
And then using fancy algorithms was able
to cross reference the traits to work
our way back for the first time to a
composite picture of what we think our
great, great grandma look like. So
now Seattle, a radio lab exclusive.
We present to you our
great, great, great, great
here. A giant rodent costume
thing runs out onto the stage.
All right, well this
is what she looks like.
And we got to point out certain
anatomical features that Papa scientists
admiration. First of all, she has
very, very pink and fleshy ears,
so show them that and
a pale soft underbelly.
It was all very nice for as
Jad is now demonstrating,
could you show them your profile
just so they can see your head?
Her skull is considered either
rat flight or a crocodilian.
You could go either way, but she
does have enormous BD, black eyes,
fleshy pink nose and would
you show them your teeth?
She's kind of proud of her teeth
because they can tear flesh,
they can rip medicine. She is an omnivore.
However, here was the issue.
You was the issue that we ran into when
we asked Maureen and the scientist who
did this work. We were like, okay, now
we've got an image of this creature.
That's amazing. What do we call her?
What is her name? This
was Maureen's response.
Its official name is the
hypothetical placental mammal
kind of a name. Was fat suddenly feeling
bad for this little creature? Well,
it's not something that we thought of as
we were sort of visibly working on the
paper. But then a funny
thing happened. Our producer,
Molly was talking to Maria
and she was saying, Jesus,
such an awful name and
Maureen system, Molly, well,
you can name it, and
Molly says to Marie, wait,
are you serious in Maureen
System, Ali? I don't know.
Are you serious? So we're like, hell yeah,
we're serious. Let's
crowd source this, right?
This is what mammals do these
days. We crowd source. I mean,
think of this opportunity. A
little radio show gets the name,
the ancestor of us all. So we
put out the call to the Internet.
We got a thousand submissions
in response. Great names.
Like let's send doors first.
First at Burs de Nova. Oh Ba, eh,
after eight rounds of voting, the
winning name was, wait for it,
wait for it, wait for it.
[inaudible]
on the screen. You see the following
letters appear one after another, s, c, h,
r, e. W. D, I, n. G, e, r,
shooting her,
shooting her.
I can't even tell you what a
crisis this was for the staff.
It's just such a bad day
and the whole experience made us wonder,
should we have died in that asteroid?
Do we deserve to be here? [inaudible]
so if you're asking yourself,
what is the moral of our story,
here's what we've shown you.
But we have a big mighty species
that died and then a smaller species,
which is you and I, we take it's place.
So you've gotten death and you've gotten
resurrection and you got it maybe in a
single afternoon. So that's
the argument we're making here.
This is Jay Molossia's
argument that it was boom over.
I mean it is the suddenness
of, of the whole over
that is kind of unimaginable.
I mean like there you are,
one day you have evolved over millions
of years to be this long neck,
beautiful creatures,
70 feet from your nose to your
ass and then tail or tail.
And then in an afternoon, like I'm on
one Tuesday afternoons, suddenly you,
everyone you knew gone.
Yeah. But there are other ways to
think about this. The extinction yes,
was sudden, but in the grand sweep of
time it wasn't. Yeah, really. In the end.
It was just a moment in a stream of
endless change cause everything we see
around us, the tallest
mountains, the size of oceans,
the animals about us that seem
so different from ourselves.
Every category that we have in
our heads that seems so permanent,
blurs given enough time,
mountains erode and become
hills. That beaches,
animals changed in any kind of all
kinds of ways and the only thing that's
constant, it's always is change.
You like to think of ourselves, we
humans are somehow inevitable or crucial.
Pivotal. The past was a time and
we were missing in the future.
We'll always have us in
it, but that's an illusion.
Says this great science
writer, Lauren Isley.
We are wrecked dolls made out
of many ages and skins. He says,
changelings who in wood nests or he
is still the uncouth guys and waddling
amphibians.
We've played such roles for infinitely
longer ages and we had been men.
Our identity is a dream
[inaudible].
We are process not reality.
What we call realities as Isley
is an illusion of the day light,
the light of our own particular day.
[inaudible].
Yeah,
just a couple of notes before we go
on. Uh, that whole dinosaur thing,
but the sudden fast end,
that is just a theory. Uh,
verdict is obviously still
out. In fact, in 2011,
a team of scientists published a paper
saying that maybe the asteroid that hit
the earth that created that
devastation was not that distinct,
but another asteroid
with a different name,
but with the same size and dimensions
and all that. So who knows? Also,
when I said to the people up in the
balcony, if you were in the balcony,
you might've been killed off by heat.
I think that turns out
to be a little bit wrong.
If you've been in the
shallow ocean of the day,
he would've been acid rain and some other
factors would have been in not so much
heat.
Okay, so this is the part of the
show coming up where we, uh, we, we,
we traveled with a bunch of different
comedians. Patton, Oswald, Simon Amstel,
Ophir Eisenberg, Kurt
Braunohler. Actually, Kurt
opened this particular show.
You can see his full set at
radiolab.org/live super funny.
But on this night, we had two comedians.
And so right at this spot in the
middle of the show, out walks a guy,
one of the most talented
mammals he looks like, actually,
it's like someone with his
finger in an electric socket.
Huge amounts of here that are
standing like, ouch. You know,
like he's got a halo. His name
[inaudible]. We're just
going to play his whole set.
It's a little Seattle specific in
spots, but it's just, well, hello.
Hello, hello,
hello. What I get done.
And then [inaudible] 11
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] you can eat
the, I could eat more.
Oh, you're the height. Warm music.
Yeah. Zoom. Yeah.
Zoom more room.
Microsoft.
Thank you. Um, this is a,
this is a moment that you
have to take, uh, if you can,
uh, and if you can't, uh, you
know, then you've lost it. But,
um, once you have it, once
you possess the moment, um,
you can do so many things with it. Um,
a lot of people tend to
just exist within it. Um,
others pawn it off to
moment brokers. Um, uh,
or if you're big fan fan of
moment. Shawn's, uh, um, you, um,
I can do that. Uh, also the moment,
a moment, glory blend of coffee,
single origin from Argentina is excellent.
You can get that at most
Bauhaus or participating in
Stumptown coffee roasters.
Um, so definitely check that out.
I'm really stoked that we finally
closed down that awful Bauhaus. Um,
coffee and books. It was just
what a terrible location, right?
You know, right on a like a corner where
you can see it really visibly. And, um,
I don't like that. Um,
and, and I called the,
the city, the city
comptroller and I just said,
we need to get rid of it and
we need to get rid of many,
many buildings cause there's a lot of
those buildings are so old up on Capitol
Hill, it's just, it gets, it gets old. Um,
and so I'd like to replace them with
new constructions, um, mostly glass,
some contemporary metal. Um,
and I want to be able to see the
architect's idea and then see them have to
shave off about 40% of that idea,
um,
by replacing a lot of the materials
with cheaper versions of the original
design. Um,
I enjoy seeing that and I would rather
see that than in a coffee shop that
promotes, um,
a type of communal living that can only
happen in an area that it is located in.
I just prefer it.
That's what I prefer. That's just me.
Sorry guys.
I love new buildings. Okay. Maria? My,
my, um, okay. So, um,
obviously as you know,
uh, Seattle is, is, uh, is, is
becoming Vancouver. And the thing is,
um,
I'm going to do a song,
um, that is about that.
So you guys can get a little bit more
used to the, the Vancouver Culture, um,
that is spreading down
Canada, Canada,
um, little, uh, uh, Mr.
Rogers reference, but, um,
Canada is Atlanta may belief.
Okay,
here we go. Oh,
okay. Okay. Here we go.
Any big fans of anybody born after 1990?
Yeah, that's about the
tonality you'd expect. Um,
why is it always higher?
I don't understand that.
Um, okay. Anyways, um, so you're
gonna know this reference.
This is a from the old,
uh, buck Rogers series,
Biggie, Biggie, Biggie, g, Buck,
you know, that kind of stuff.
So that's for you guys after nine to 98
so you guys can relate to what I'm doing
on stage. And so,
um,
I hope you like this. This is, this
is definitely, definitely a song.
Okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
good moment that you
[inaudible] got home on my own food.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] right.
[inaudible] thank you very much.
Um, if you're, if you're
down, um, at a, in, in,
in Ballard and having
a good time, um, it's,
it's because there's so much
Scandinavian energy there that
they just do, they just do it. Right.
Um,
so when you hit the sunset
tavern and you're like,
why isn't this turned into a glass tower?
It's because the power of Norway,
it's Norway. They're going to screw
with that. You know what I mean?
Like Norway at all. No, what I'm saying,
there's no way out of this. I mean, you're
basically, you know what I'm saying?
It's like a hotdog. You know, you
think you want it and you're like, ah,
probably not. But
[inaudible]
um, and I'm pretty stoked
I've said this before,
but I am going to say it again
just because we're in Seattle.
I am pretty stoked. Um, I balance, uh,
of Vivace, um, being
replaced by the Starbucks.
I just think that it makes
sense. It makes sense.
Let the people who do it really well
do it better. You know what I'm saying?
That's what I'm saying.
So this song is going to be one of
those songs where you're gonna think to
yourself, is this better than
the original? Maybe. Okay.
Alright.
It's called pastiche in lieu
of originality. Here we go.
[inaudible] hey. Hi.
Whoa.
[inaudible] I want to
talk in the ones that
[inaudible]
I got it.
Whoa, Whoa, whoa. A little girl.
[inaudible] characters reading
her name's [inaudible].
[inaudible]
Yay. You, you
know, the thing is a, the thing is
I think
using, using, using logic, um, I think,
you know, obviously it, it is
smart to name a company after a,
a character from Battlestar
Galactica, but I just,
it makes sense.
And that's why I'm starting my
own coffee business called cylons.
Cylons coffee is the best coffee
[inaudible].
I have a new movie coming out
called silence of the lambs and, um,
it's a theme song, uh, is done
by Garfunkel notes. Of course,
you can probably guess what that song
is called a the sound of silence and,
um, which is just
[inaudible]
and sometimes
and sometimes,
yeah,
it's the sound of silence. Okay. So,
um, this song, thank
you for my next trick.
No, it's been a pleasure. This is
my last, uh, Radicchio lab and I am,
and I'll say no, in all seriousness.
That's a totally different show,
but I'm radio lab. Um, it's
been awesome, man. I mean, uh,
I discovered some really great friends
the first time I did something, um,
for radio lab and I continue to find
great friendships and a love and passion
for sound and um,
science and knowledge and art. And
so I think that, um, I'm lucky,
lucky to be a part of it in this small
way that I am. So thanks, Radiolab,
wherever you are.
Okay. So this is a, it's
a quick song that goes.
Okay. Okay. And, uh, this song is,
this song is a, that's
a, that's a good one.
Okay. There we go.
[inaudible] oh.
[inaudible] the snow.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
but no, we know
and is nine.
Oh Du du, du Du du Du, Du, Du, Du, Du
[inaudible].
When I facing those dumb lizards walking
cross this barren plane last born baby,
ya can go and blame when
those [inaudible] go.
Tear into the sky,
squawking with the laser precision
swooping down seeking breeze and no wait.
That shining
little.in the distance is
not a super extra shiny star.
All the astro physicist dinosaurs
would have said in that time before the
[inaudible].
Uh Huh.
Matt.
It was great to see the
earth concoct his dreams.
Large Lizard family,
those lizards made sounds and attacked
each other in more coats and clothing.
But whoa,
well all of that got burned off in the
evidence of the natural intellectual
society may not be
apparent to us. Whoa. Ooh.
I know
what happened to the sleaze stacks.
What happened to blow
those slurping sleaze,
eggs moving,
and probably a top speed of three miles
per hour or the aliens that donated
genetic material to the hominy hands in
order to create the society people that
we are now.
This explains our fascination for diamonds
and goals because we've just kinda
dug it up for their spaceships. Oh,
Yay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] no knowing me, knowing
me, nobody. Nobody. Nobody,
nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody.
Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody.
Nobody. Nobody. Nobody my age.
Nobody. Nobody. Nobody. Nobody.
[inaudible]
okay.
Thank you so much guys.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
let's just take stock
for a second. Robert,
we did our super fast radical dyno ending.
Reggie did his Reggie ending, which,
which you never quite sure
what he's saying. You know?
Can you imagine we have
scripts having magic.
If I just want you over through the river
[inaudible]
it would be outer space, man.
Okay, so what's the, what's next?
What's our next step? I think we're
ready for the pink ending now.
The pink thing, you mean like the color?
Yeah, this is the one that answered,
I think the most basic question you
could ask in a show like this. This asks,
when did endings begin?
It's a serious question. That's a
weird one. When did endings begin?
Wouldn't there always, I mean
the moment you had beginnings,
wouldn't that then imply an end because
the beginnings have to do something and
you'd think so, but if you think hard
about the origin of the universe,
I would propose that
when the universe began,
which by some interpretation was a huge
explosion of energy which then condensed
and cooled into matter that that whole
event came in without any notion of
endings at all. Huh? When you get
matter, when you get that condensation,
you get a list of elements which we can
now turn to in the periodic table of
elements with which you I'm sure very
familiar and enjoy every evening before
dining or sleeping. Keith here now puts
the periodic table up on the screen.
So if we look at this at this chart,
let me start up in the upper left hand
side of the hydrogen and we move through
it, the helium and lithium and beryllium
and Boron and carbon and on and on.
As we move through the list,
I can tell you that every one of the
first 82 elements on this chart with two
exceptions, which I'll
mention in a minute,
every one of these has a version of
itself that goes on forever and ever and
ever until the end of time. Every one
of these you're saying is immortal.
Is that what you're saying? Yes. Now
here's the thing. When we get to, um,
number 83 B, that's business.
I would argue that this is
where the universe invents
in things. Really what is,
what is business? It's a rock,
a kind of a shiny black rock.
And you're saying this shiny black rock
is, is, is where death begins. Yes. Yes.
I would say that that's a fair
apply. Would that be well,
because all the atoms at the bottom of
this chart are a little heavier than the
ones on the top.
Meaning they have lots and lots
of of neutrons and protons here.
Keith brings up an image of a
business. Adam with lots of jiggling,
protons and neutrons. There's
so many of them. As you can see,
they're having a little trouble holding
their themselves together and French
scientists studying this. Adam
recently determined that inevitably,
inevitably something will happen to
this. Adam. It goes something like this.
Protons and neutrons fly off the atom
and Amazingly Roberts Pew was perfectly
timed in this case with Keith hitting
the button to do it visually and that had
never happened before. Whoa.
Do that again. Okay. I don't
think I can do it twice. No,
you don't add sound effects. I'm to
the sound effects when you do that
one more time. Oh Man.
Now you're bringing strike made him angry.
Stop it.
The point I'm trying to make
Keith, is that this Adam,
when it loses protons,
it loses its identity.
What an Adam decays this.
Adam is no longer bismuth if it doesn't
have the right number of programs.
That's the way chemistry you were saying
like as it as it sheds its protons and
neutrons, it's dying. That's
right. Now here's the cool thing.
When we go back to the chart to number
83 every element after it po at room for
raw riff, dubs, dis and rig elements,
84 to one 18 also decay.
So on the periodic table you see two
teams basically that once the top there,
forever hours they go forever. And on
the bottom you have the ones that die,
right? That's correct, that's correct.
But with the two exceptions I mentioned,
I should say 43 and 61 that's
tech medium and promethium.
Nobody really likes those too.
There I find them actually unnecessary.
I'll tell you what if they,
if they mess up the whole logic here,
let's just, let's just get rid of them.
Let's to get rid of them. Get
Out, get them out of here.
We just spoke two holes into the table.
Let me just say when we
divided up like this,
now you can see that bismuth is at a
dividing line, maybe of the universe.
Cause this is like, this is where you see,
it's like the KT boundary
with the dinosaurs. This is a,
this is the for everything.
For everything, but the cute,
cool thing is business is
pretty good for you. Really.
People swallow a little bits of business
every time they get Tommy x to do this
all the time. You recognize this color,
maybe screen fills the think pink.
I mentioned, do you recognize the
product associated with this color?
You know this product. Pepto-Bismol.
Yeah, but just say it, right?
Say it the way it should be. Said pepto.
What did I say? What? Bismol no, no.
Say the only, the first syllable pepto is,
are you applying that you're playing
the Bismol stands for business.
I don't have to imply
it's true. [inaudible]
I don't know Robert and I was with
you right up until this point,
but if I had to guess,
I would say that Bismol is just the name
of the dude that made pepto B j Jake f
Bismol. I'm telling you that
each bottle of pink liquid,
there are little black rocks and that's
just the truth. I don't know man.
I don't know. [inaudible] relevant to me.
I hear Robert Appears on the
screen in chemistry goggles,
you know, laboratories with
eight chemistry teacher.
By my time in Brooklyn and what you
then see us do is we take in tablets of
Pepto B. We Mush them up with a
mortar and pestle. We add some water,
we add some hydrochloric acid,
we shake it some aluminum,
and you get to see little bits of
black rock precipitate out of the pepto
bismal. Lots of them. I was surprised
at how much black stuff is in there.
And then I showed the test
tube to Jack Jad. Look,
you can't deny scientific fact at hiding
inside every single pepto bismal tablet
is pure street-level
grade crystal business
in the side, pepto B.
You will find an element
that not only cures eggs,
barely and introduces death
to the universe. I think
it's such a great element.
We should have a toast to
business. Yeah, it's toast.
[inaudible]
can we close the segment by both
of us taking two big pint glasses,
filling them up to the top
with pepto Bismol Chunky
[inaudible].
You always did it faster just by a hair.
So special thanks to Gail Carnow,
my chemist Sam keen who
helped write this thing.
Lauren swarthout who got us study,
got us the lab connection
and Zack Fan and who shot it,
edited it and re edited
it and re edited it.
In typical Radiolab fashion,
it's there now we will pause
only to do some business.